قتال تقابل هذه الكتلة
النمساوي وعائلة فالتر
باتريون أو القرصنة على الحديث 14
الرشاشات أدناه
أنتجت عائلات كلاشينكوف
بلغاريا اطلاق النار وصاخبة
الذين يتقاضون رواتبهم
إنه قانون تكوين الجمعيات
البنادق المصنوعة يدويا بغرفة
عيار كبير يتراوح من 12.7 إلى
ثلاثة وعشرون ملم إلى الخارج
فعالة جدا قرع انه من دولهم
ألمانيا فرنسا باكستان وبلغاريا
لدينا أتامان العليا جزء من
عينات الكأس
تويوتا لاند للسيارات المدنية
طراد لزيادة أمنهم
الأماكن الأكثر ضعفًا
اكتمل الحجز الإضافي
القوات الحكومية الحرف اليدوية
تجهيز مستودعات السجون تحت الأرض و
أيضا تتحرك الوحدة
الاحتمالات مع المواد المحلولة يدويًا
مع عناصر ملفتة جاهزة من
قطع من الأسلاك
المسامير والبراغي باستخدام الصمامات
على حد سواء محلية الصنع و
منتظم من 120 ملم